foreign
i'm major maynard of air force special
operations command
i'm a recon officer
go ahead and get checked out on the gear
a description of the items will appear
in your glasses
me
not sure if the uh
tracking bullets will work
the emp appears to have taken out the
gps data links and the broad range radar
systems
we'll have to navigate by the stars
just like world war ii
delta will be joining our mission in
panama have you met their captain ivan
right
a lot of team names are classified so
you can call me bob
no offense but i've got a job to do and
that does include babysitting you and
your cowboys what the hell's your
problem
your job
is to sniff out the enemy
so the hunters can bag the prey
if our little
hound dog goes off mission
he gets put down
gentlemen
we've just entered panamanian airspace
gear up
sand fire port side act it's a club king
releasing counter measures
we'll have to board if this keeps up if
you can steady out the aircraft we can
make it down in our exodus they'll blow
you out of the sky
stella get these boys to a safe lc i'm
off the beach
ah
big mouse this is your work
done
you